When my daughter was in kindergarten, I
sometimes volunteered in her classroom.
One day, as I was organizing paperwork
in the back of the room, the teacher
gathered the students to the rug where
they sat cross-legged at her feet. As
she talked to the class, a wiggly boy in
the front named [music] Jack tapped her
foot gently with his foot. She said,
"Please don't do that." And he stopped
for a minute,
>> [music]
>> but then tapped her foot again. She
corrected him again, so sternly that it
caught my attention. The third time that
he tapped her foot, she [music] lost her
temper, chastising him severely and
yelling at him that he was being
defiant. Another time when I was in this
kindergarten class, I was helping the
kids as they did an art project drawing
animals. Suddenly, I heard the teacher
scold a boy, "Chase, what are you doing?
Goats are not purple. Start over." I was
stunned. The teacher was young and
friendly, and she was always really nice
to me and very kind to my daughter. What
I and other parents noticed over [music]
time was that this teacher often
exploded disproportionately at boys. And
remember, these were 5-year-olds, barely
out of preschool. They clung to their
parents when they got dropped off at
school. Some of them still [music] took
naps. So, what was going on? Could it be
that this teacher really didn't like
boys? Or maybe didn't like men? More
broadly, is misandry real? If so, where
does it come from? What are the effects?
And what do we do about it?
This video has the potential to be one
of the most controversial I've ever
shared, and I realize [music] it might
make some people mad. Some of you may
think I'm not hard enough on men, and
some might think I'm not hard enough on
women. And listen, plenty of people out
there will offer a hot take on misandry
to get you riled up for battle in the
gender war. That's just not who I am. My
goals are clearer understanding [music]
and solutions to the gender war that are
grounded in love. [music]
So, stick with me. Let's see if we can
figure this out. First, what is
misandry? The word misandry is from
Greek. Miso meaning hatred, and andry
meaning men. And it's as straightforward
as that. It means dislike of, contempt
for, or ingrained prejudice against men.
[music] Just as misogyny means dislike
of, contempt for, or ingrained prejudice
against women. So, do some women really,
truly hate men, and not just like
dislike individual men who behave badly,
but really hate men in general because
they're men? Well, yes.
And in fact, as I talked with people in
preparation for this video, I found that
many women felt more general anger at
and even dislike of men in general than
I expected. They described feeling
conflicted about it because they loved
their own male family members, but their
anger at patriarchy and so many bad
experiences with so many men, both
personal and large-scale societal, had
started [music] to add up to negative
feelings toward men in general. If
that's you, you might already be feeling
defensive. [music] So, let me establish
a couple of things right off the bat.
Misandry, hatred of men, and misogyny,
hatred [music] of women, are both
hurtful. But they have not caused an
equal amount of harm in our world.
The impact is not even comparable. On an
individual, physical level, the simple
size and strength difference [music]
between a typical male and typical
female makes for a grossly uneven fight.
In general, a man can do far more damage
to a woman than a woman can do to a man.
Add to that patriarchal [music]
entitlement where a man becomes furious
if he's not obeyed or shown the
deference that he thinks he deserves,
[music] and you get a world where, as
Margaret Atwood said, "Men are afraid
that women will laugh at them. Women are
afraid that men will kill them."
The data bears this out. In 2019 in the
United States, there were 477 men
murdered by women,
>> [music]
>> and 1,647
women murdered by men.
And the large-scale societal impact of
misandry versus misogyny is also vastly
different. Some women do cause real harm
to men, but in relatively small numbers.
So, in this way, misandry is like a
destructive bacteria that a few people
pass on to people they come in direct
contact with. Misogyny, on the other
hand, is like a destructive bacteria
that made it into the world's water
supply. The impact is exponentially
different. And by [music] the way, if
you meet a men's rights activist who
argues that misandry is systemic, that
men are more oppressed than women,
simply show him this photo, or this
photo, or this photo, or these photos.
As historian Gerda Lerner said,
"Throughout history, men have been
oppressed for many reasons:
>> [music]
>> their race, their religion, their social
class, etc. But women have also been
oppressed for all of those same reasons,
and they have been oppressed [music]
because they are women." So, I repeat,
the impact of misandry and the impact of
misogyny are not even close, and it
would be a gross, ridiculous instance of
false equivalence to claim otherwise.
And with all of that said, girls and
women do really harm men sometimes, and
that matters to me. Feminist activist
Audre Lorde said, "I'm thankful that one
of my children is male, since that helps
to keep me honest. Every line I write
shrieks, 'There are no easy solutions.'"
Audre Lorde loved her son and wanted his
precious soul to be safe and to flourish
in this world,
>> [music]
>> just as I feel about my son and all the
boys and men in my life, and boys and
men in general.
>> [music]
>> So, today we're going to take an honest
look at misandry through four
representative examples. Think about
whether you've seen examples like this
in your life, and then later we'll
analyze what's going on. First, a
fictional example. In Charles Dickens'
masterpiece, Great Expectations, [music]
a young orphan boy named Philip Pirrip
meets a woman named Miss Havisham and
her adopted daughter, Estella. Miss
Havisham hates Pip, and she encourages
Estella to break Pip's heart. You can
break his heart.
Why did Miss Havisham hate men so much?
Second, a real-life example. Not long
ago, one of my nephews was on a Zoom
call with his middle school classmates,
and a girl started writing in the chat
that men, implying all men, were
horrible and abusive. My nephew had
never heard anything like that before,
and no doubt thinking about his dad and
his grandpas and his brothers and
uncles, ventured in confusion, "I don't
think all men are like that."
The girl wrote back profanities and
[music] "You should kill yourself." She
literally wrote that. I saw screenshots
of the whole conversation. Thank
goodness my nephew told his parents
about it, and they helped him process
what had happened. But what if he hadn't
told them? What if that experience had
gone deep into his heart and festered
there? And then what if another girl at
school bullied him the following year,
which did happen, by the way? And then
what if he fell in with some boys at
school who introduced him to the
manosphere?
Here's a less dramatic, but extremely
common example. I can think of multiple
women I know who are chronically curt
and critical of their husbands. Their
husbands aren't perfect, but they love
their wives, and they do their best to
make them happy. The [music] wives just
seem to be seething with resentment. In
fact, this type of grumpy, critical wife
is a trope in a lot of cultures. Where
does this stereotype of the angry woman
come from? I know multiple men who were
profoundly wounded by their mothers'
angry, volatile behavior in their
childhoods. Then, just a few weeks ago,
I was talking with my friend Shirley
Draper.
>> [music]
>> Shirley's kids are grown now, and she
shared with me that her sons had come to
her recently and given her some feedback
[music] that was really hard for her to
hear. She told me I could record her
story to share on this video. I I had
three sons, and I just felt like that I
was constantly trying to make sure that
they understood, [music]
you know, this is, you know, men have
this privilege, and and you don't take
advantage of that, and you shouldn't
expect, you know, anything special
because you're a man, and and but then
more than that, it was the conversations
I would have with my friends, or that my
my boys would overhear, or, you know,
anything that would come along. So,
somebody would talk about male privilege
or anything, and I of course had a lot
to say about [music] it. And so, it it
really showed up in a way
um to my son
as man-hating. And [music] it showed up
even even beyond that as his inherent
trait of having a Y chromosome was bad
and wrong. Without having any kind of
productive or helpful male role model
was was very harmful to him. And so, you
know, we had a conversation not that
long ago where he said to me, "I need
you to understand what it was like for
me as a man to be raised in a man-hating
household."
I know Shirley, And like all mothers,
she loves her kids and she would do
absolutely [music] anything for them.
She literally left her fundamentalist
polygamous community to save them.
And she was absolutely devastated to
[music] learn that she had hurt them.
Where did her hatred of men come from?
She'll tell us in a minute and it's a
powerful insight. But first, let's
circle back to all of these examples and
figure out what's going on underneath.
Miss Havisham.
What on earth did this lady have against
sweet little Pip? Well, Miss Havisham
had been engaged to a man who pretended
to love her but was secretly conspiring
to con her out of her fortune.
>> [music]
>> And then he jilted her at the altar. She
was so heartbroken by this man's cruelty
that she stayed stuck in time at her
abandoned wedding, literally still
wearing her wedding dress.
And that wound turned into hot infected
rage [music]
at men in general, which she took out on
poor 7-year-old Pip. Have you ever known
a woman to carry [music] past masculine
wounds into her relationships with other
men?
Next, the middle school girl who told my
nephew [music] to end his life.
I don't know that girl, but it seems to
me that either she had seen men do some
really terrible things
or she had been hearing women express a
lot of vitriol toward men. Maybe [music]
in person, maybe online, maybe both.
Have you ever known a woman to absorb
collective cultural rage and then direct
that rage at an undeserving target?
Next, the bitter critical wife. First of
all, let's just say that the shrew trope
perpetuates unfair derogatory
stereotypes about women. In patriarchal
society, men have historically grown up
expecting women to obey and comply. So,
a woman who simply has her own opinion
would be perceived as difficult. But
even if this woman is legitimately mean
to her husband, have you ever known a
woman who was told her whole life to not
ask questions, to be quiet and small,
who sacrificed her career and her
individual growth and development so
everyone else in her family could pursue
theirs? Have you ever known a woman who
was financially dependent on her husband
to the point of having to ask for an
allowance
>> [music]
>> and had no real vote or voice in her
religion? If so,
can you imagine why such a woman might
feel a little resentment? Does it make
sense that if this woman had never been
taught what to do with that resentment
or been given any tools to communicate
it, that that bottled up frustration
might leak out or explode at the men
closest to her? Are you seeing a theme
here? What if the root of misandry is
actually misogyny?
Just think about it. Misogyny is about
controlling, hurting, and depressing
women.
Misandry is about trying [music] to
protect against misogyny.
Misandry is a response to the harms of
patriarchy.
So now, my friend Shirley Draper, whose
son told her it had hurt him to grow up
in a man-hating household. I was born
and raised FLDS, which is fundamentalist
Latter-Day Saint and it's the the group
that practiced polygamy with, you know,
infamous Warren Jeffs at the helm. So so
my context for this conversation is is
about being raised in this really
overtly patriarchal misogynistic
society, [music]
being raised with these messages that
were so contrary to my soul and then
learning to come out of that and trying
to fight against it in a way that
I find out later isn't as effective as I
wish it had been.
>> [music]
>> My cultural history is one of of high
patriarchy and
>> [music]
>> um having different rules for men than
for women. And so uh it's it started off
it started off with the entire setup,
but I think in utero
>> [music]
>> where where my dad was really abusive,
physically abusive to my mom, um really
had a massive massive impact on me. And
so just my entire life, I remember
chafing under these rules, the separate
rules for me than there were for my
brothers just because uh an an inherent
trait that was encoded in my DNA and
that was for me the lack of a Y
chromosome. That was literally the only
difference between my me and my brothers
and yet they had a lot more privilege
than I did.
>> [music]
>> It it was very present for me from from
my first breath. My my earliest memories
are of a [music] need to protect people
who were being harmed and also this this
rage about inequality, [music]
inequity. And so every time I'd see
that, I would just it would just make me
so angry and and made me also very
hypersensitive
to any whisper [music] of it
to where a lot of times I would see it
where it didn't really even exist, you
know, [music] somebody somebody was
trying to express care and it would come
across to me as control. So yeah, that
the hypersensitivity and the rage
[music] were were ever present. I got
this feedback that I was a man-hater and
and from my perspective, it was just
why? Because I'm not putting you on a
pedestal and worshipping you? Is that
what it means to be a man-hater? Um
[music]
and so I remember being told that a lot,
you know, you think differently than
others and and eventually I just ended
up thinking I'm literally the only one
in the world who
thinks this because I kept getting that
feedback. [music]
But but I didn't internalize it. I
didn't take it in that that I was a
man-hater
uh because, you know, for me it was just
like, no, I'm I'm demanding of you what
is due to me and that doesn't make me a
man-hater and you, you know, you don't
get to tell me that.
>> [music]
>> It never occurred to me
that my being [music] a warrior and and
really communicating in violent ways
was harming my child.
And and so
you know, I have to learn non-violent
ways of communicating. So, one of the
things that I've learned over the years
of studying, you know, people that I
want to be like, Brené Brown, you know,
shaming is so violent. And so if I'm
looking at the message that I'm trying
to get across of here's what we need to
change, if I'm doing it in a shaming
way,
>> [music]
>> automatically people are going to be
defensive and and digging in. And you
know, and I think I think because we do
that so much as a society, we create
[music] extremism. We create, you know,
right now we've got a lot of young men
that are really leaning [music] into
patriarchy and and male dominance and I
think [music] it's probably a reaction
to their feeling shameful about who they
were and their, you know, ascribed
traits, inherent traits that they were
born with. And so I'm thinking, you
know, as a society, we can do so much
better
by by having these gentler messages and
these including and helping people
[music] understand rather than saying,
you know, you have so much privilege,
you should be ashamed of that. That was
something my son was born into. If I
want people to have have compassion for
people who are born into [music]
polygamy, why wouldn't I want people to
have compassion for other, you know,
>> [music]
>> things they're born into, other
privilege they have just because, you
know, I have white privilege. I know
[music] that, right? So how do we have
conversations about what it means and
how we can do better rather than saying
you're bad. I can be a feminist. [music]
I can help unders- help people
understand why the patriarchy is harmful
>> [music]
>> without undermining and shaming and and
making someone feel like, you know,
guilty for having been born a man.
I'm so grateful to Shirley for sharing
her story. And one quick note, after we
recorded this conversation, Shirley told
me that she hoped she made it clear that
she was not saying that women need to do
men's emotional work for them. Women
take on that burden far too often.
>> [music]
>> So I do want to emphasize that Shirley
was speaking specifically as a mother to
a son. And that's a unique relationship.
[music]
I wanted to feature that mother-son
relationship though because Shirley
isn't the only mother who has shared a
story like that with me. Multiple
grief-stricken mothers have reached
[music] out to me saying that their
unhealed patriarchal wounds have done
[music] profound harm to the boys and
men in their lives. In my opinion, we as
individuals and as a society have
[music] to care about that. We have to
care about our sons and husbands and
fathers and brothers [music] and
nephews. And when we chase down that
misandry to its source, to its root,
over and over again, we see that at the
root is a giant unhealed wound in women
caused [music] by misogyny. So what do
we do? How do we heal so that [music] we
break the cycle and pass on less trauma
to the next generation? I have three
practical [music] suggestions. One
specifically for men, one specifically
for women, and one for everyone. [music]
First, an invitation for men.
One quote I love is from the late
Buddhist monk Thich Nhat Hanh, who said,
>> [music]
>> "When another person makes you suffer,
it is because they suffer deeply within
themselves and their suffering is
spilling over."
In that [music] spirit, men, if you know
a woman who seems upset a lot or seems
to dislike men in general, would you be
able to invite her to have a
conversation with you where you just
listen with the goal of understanding
the patriarchal wounds that she could be
carrying? [music]
These wounds might come from her
childhood watching her dad yell at her
mom,
or watching her whole community [music]
ignore and infantilize women.
Her patriarchal wounds might be a few
giant ones or 1 million less obvious
ones
>> [music]
>> or both.
And she might not have ever had the
words to express her pain before. That
might be why it has been leaking out
sideways, manifesting itself in anger at
you.
>> [music]
>> Would you be able to just sit with her
and try to understand? Maybe even more
challenging,
>> [music]
>> would you be able to accept
responsibility for the patriarchal pain
you may have caused?
>> [music]
>> Even if you did your best, even if the
bad actions of other men are not your
fault, which they're not. [music]
Even if you have your own wounds,
would you be able to address those
wounds at a different time
>> [music]
>> and just sit with this woman and be a
caring witness to her experience? Would
you be willing to do this multiple
[music] times?
Would you be able to tell her that she
can take as long as she needs, [music]
that you're there for her while she does
this Herculean work of stopping an
intergenerational cycle of pain [music]
so that it doesn't get passed on to the
next generation?
Next, an invitation for women.
In her book The Will to Change: Men,
Masculinity, and Love, one of my great
heroes, feminist scholar bell hooks,
wrote,
"To create loving men,
>> [music]
>> we must love males.
Caring about men because of what they do
for us is not the same as loving males
for simply being.
>> [music]
>> When we love maleness, we extend our
love whether males are performing or
not.
In patriarchal culture, males are not
allowed simply to be who they are and to
glory in their unique identity. [music]
Their value is always determined by what
they do.
In an anti-patriarchal culture, males do
not have to prove their value and worth.
They know from birth that simply being
gives them value and [music] the right
to be cherished and loved. Women, if we
are feeling animosity toward men in
general,
>> [music]
>> can we look honestly at the source of
that animosity, whether that's
individual men who have hurt us or
systemic sexism in our culture? And then
can we heal those wounds inside of us so
that we can use our anger to create
change [music] in society, taking care
to not mistreat the good, kind men in
our [music] lives? If a partner or son
comes to us with hurt and pain that we
have caused, [music]
can we listen without defensiveness and
hold ourselves accountable for our
actions? [music] Can we make sure that
we are extremely careful with our words
and our energy around children? [music]
If our patriarchal wound isn't healed,
it's not time to have a baby.
>> [music]
>> It's not a good idea to become a
kindergarten teacher. Can we show the
world that the promise of feminism is
true, [music] that it's not a zero-sum
game,
that we can care about and support girls
and we can care about and support boys?
>> [music]
>> These things are not mutually exclusive.
We can work toward a world where
everyone can thrive. And now I have an
invitation for everyone. We've all been
harmed and we all bring invisible wounds
from our pasts and from our culture into
our present relationships.
>> [music]
>> It's part of the human condition and
patriarchy only makes it worse. But we
can begin healing those wounds. We can
do this through patient and
compassionate conversation with loved
ones, through therapy, [music]
through men's circles or women's
circles. There are all kinds of
modalities that can help. [music]
And I highly recommend this book called
Gender Equity and Reconciliation:
[music]
30 Years of Healing the Most Ancient
Wound in the Human Family.
But at the end of the day, no amount of
books or validation from others,
certainly no amount of sex or being
doted on or obeyed, or hustling for
others' approval,
can [music] heal our wounds. But we can
heal our wounds. And in my experience,
the thing that heals wounds and replaces
the corrosive force of hatred, whether
it be misogyny or misandry or racism or
any other kind of hatred,
is the power of love.
As Dr. Martin Luther King said,
"Darkness cannot drive out darkness.
Only light can do that.
Hate cannot drive out hate.
>> [music]
>> Only love can do that."
To illustrate this point, I want to
close with a scene from one of my
favorite movies, Moana. In the film, an
island is becoming sick. Its food
sources are dying as charred lava takes
over the vegetation. [music] Te Kā, a
ferocious fire goddess, is destroying
the island and she attacks anyone who
comes near her. Why?
>> [music]
>> Well, it turns out that the god Maui has
violated her autonomy and [music] stolen
her heart from her.
Sound familiar? Now, make no mistake, Te
Kā should be angry.
>> [music]
>> She should fight to get back what was
stolen from her. But her righteous anger
has consumed her and turned her into a
monster who destroys [music] everything
around her. She's lost herself and she
can't do any good in this state. In this
scene, Moana is nearing the end of her
grueling heroine's journey and is
confronting the terrifying [music] Te
Kā. As I watch it, I feel how powerful
it is for a person to meet [music]
another's hatred with love.
I feel that sacredness when I study
activists who have changed the world
through nonviolence.
But what I also see in this scene is an
opportunity for us to do our own
internal healing. [music]
As you watch this clip, imagine that Te
Kā symbolizes the worst [music]
hurt inside of all of us.
The hurt that can turn into hatred so
powerful that it can destroy the people
around [music] us. In this
interpretation, Te Kā is us.
And Moana is also us.
>> [music]
>> Moana is the brave healer in us that
meets the grief and rage and says,
"It's okay to be angry. [music] Someone
hurt you.
But this does not define you.
This hatred, this is not who you are.
You know [music] who you are."
It's this inner healing, this profound
[music]
self-love,
that transforms the chaotic destruction
of hatred into life-giving,
world-changing [music]
power.
Thank you so much for watching. This was
a tricky topic and I'm sure you're
having all kinds of thoughts and
feelings. So please share them with
honesty
>> [music]
>> and compassion in the comments. And then
forward this video on to a friend.